avec nous maintenant jean simard
président et chef de la direction de
l'association de l'aluminium du canada
bonsoir bonsoir alors qu'est ce qui se
passe pourquoi le marché n'est pas très
bon et décevant depuis quelques temps
c'est c'est un peu un ensemble de
facteurs à l'échelle mondiale qui
viennent affecter le prix d'une
commodité qui est un prix mondial donc
en premier lieu la surcapacité chinoise
à laquelle on avait peine à s'habituer à
venir jusqu'aujourd'hui qui est
accentuée du fait du ralentissement de
l'économie chinoise de la croissance de
l'économie et donc qui vient ajouter une
pression soutenue sur la baisse des prix
du marché
en plus de ça en europe qui entre en
contraction économique donc moins de
demande pour des produits de
consommation comme des automobiles ou
des des projets de construction
domiciliaire ou commerciales ou autres
ce qui vient affecter encore une fois la
demande pour un métal comme l'aluminium
et on vit la même situation
plus près de nous au sud aux états unis
où on voit premièrement un inventaire a
cumulé d'environ un million de véhicules
dans le parc automobile nord-américain
et vend du doigt et un ralentissement
donc de la demande des grands fabricants
américains pour le métal qui est requis
pour produire qui se traduit dans des
carnets de commandes pour le secteur
primaire qui peine à se matérialiser à
ceux à se re négocier parce que le
marché est comme un suspect et à travers
ce à travers ça on a une situation aussi
d'incertitudes quant aux guerre
tarifaire qui a fait et plus grands
blocs commerciaux au monde soit l'union
européenne avec les états unis la chine
avec les états unis est ce donc climat
d'incertitude qui vient alourdir le
processus décisionnel l'aluminium est
très liée au secteur de l'automobile
et qui dit inventaire ou stocks élevés
dit demande moins grande pour les
acteurs exactement et le métal usagers
on a vu la chine bloquait en quelque
sorte c'est
le marché du métal usagers quel est
l'impact sur les prix bien l'impact sur
les prix suivants on s'est retrouvés il
ya deux ans avec une fermeture de la
frontière chinoise à l'égard des
importations d'aluminium entre autres en
provenance de l'amérique du nord
donc ce métal deviennent jour au
lendemain disponibles sur le marché
domestique et cannibalise
progressivement des parts de marché du
métal primaire parce qu'ils coûtent
moins cher jusqu'au jour où la demande
pour le métal recyclé soit tellement
élevé que le pays rejoint le prix du
métal primaire et là c'est la
substitution sur l'autre secteur de
provisions est ce qu'un secteur comme
l'aluminium
ces précurseurs c'est un indicateur
avancé de ce qui est en train de se
passer dans l'économie c'est-à-dire un
ralentissement peut-être même une
récession
oui en fait c'est un peu un canari dans
la mine pour utiliser cette expression
on voit nous depuis le printemps 2010 9
que les commandes qui normalement ce ce
retrait au printemps vers le mois
d'avril mais pour répondre à la demande
annuelle du marché n'ont jamais repris
alors on y on a commencé à sentir un
ralentissement chez des grands acheteurs
qui s'est confirmée au fil du temps à
venir jusqu'à cet été ou résolument on
est forcé de constater qu'on entre dans
un cycle manufacturier de contraction
après 10 ans d'expansion
quand on regarde les prix on a préparé
un graphique sur 12 mois
on voit un recul de 15% du prix de la
tonne d'aluminium depuis un an sur le
marché londonien on est passé de 2000 à
1700 à peu près si j'avais reculé de 18
mois la baisse est même de 30% à ce
moment là est ce que cette tendance à la
baisse va se poursuivre on s'attend ce
que la fin de toute fin de 2019 soit
dans la séquence de cette baisse de la
demande et donc du pli et on s'attend à
ce que 20 20 soit encore une pire année
plusieurs des prévisionnistes points de
verts
un métal qui se transigerait entre les
1600 l'aimé même les 1500 dollars la
tonne en est à 1700 on est à 1700 ont
selon italie dans les 1600 je pense que
le meilleur indicateur dans tout ça
c'est qu'au prix d'aujourd'hui dans les
1700 on est exactement là où on était il
ya 30 ans en termes de primes avec les
coudes aujourd'hui ce qui veut dire des
marges bénéficiaires qui se sont
réduites de moitié sur 30 ans donc des
ralentissements comme on voit des
mauvaises nouvelles comme on voit comme
rio tinto aujourd'hui qui décident de
suspendre des projets au québec on
pourrait en voir d'autres et y assister
même à des fermetures ou à des
suppressions d'emplois on va
certainement voir d'autres nouvelles
comme ça qu'ils vont percolé le au fil
du temps et plus le prix va baisser et
plus le le volume de capacité à risque
dans le monde vont augmenter et les
fermetures vont malheureusement se
produire chez des producteurs privés
plutôt que des capacités qui sont
financés subventionné par des états
aujourd'hui 70% de la compacte de la
capacité mondiale est détenue par des
fonds souverains la chine
la norvège l'inde en partie et le
moyen-orient alors l'un des endroits qui
sont les plus sensibles à des situations
économiques comme celle que nous vivons
sont les endroits où la production est
détenu privé mans donc en amérique du
nord aux états unis en europe donc nos
installations ici au québec sont à
risque sont pas à risque parce que on a
atteint des niveaux de productivité qui
nous ont permis de faire face à la
tempête
mais ça c'était pour le passé il faut
continuer d'améliorer notre productivité
notre enjeu c'est d'amener
l'automatisation et la robotisation pour
être encore plus productif et se
maintenir dans les quartiers les plus
performants au monde gens se marrent
merci beaucoup merci bien je vous en
prie